The trajectory estimation
problem that we considered
gives you a first glimpse
into a large field
that deals with
linear normal models.
In this segment, I
will just give you
a preview of what
happens in that field,
although, we will not attempt
to prove or justify anything.
What happens in this
field is that we're
dealing with models where
there are some underlying
independent normal
random variables.
And then, the random
variables of interest,
the unknown parameters
and the observations,
can all be expressed
as linear functions
of these independent normals.
Since linear functions
of independent normals
are normal, in
particular, this means
that the Theta j and the Xi are
all normal random variables.
Carrying out inference
within this class of models
goes under the name
of linear regression.
One can proceed using
pretty much the same steps
as we had in the trajectory
estimation problem
and write down formulas
for the posterior.
And it turns out
that in every case,
the posterior of
the parameter vector
takes a form which is the
exponential of and the negative
of a quadratic function
of the parameters.
And this means, in
particular, that in order
to find the MAP estimate
of the vector Theta, what
we need to do is
to just minimize
this quadratic function
with respect to theta.
And minimizing a
quadratic function
is done by taking
derivatives and setting them
to zero which leads us to a
system of linear equations,
exactly as in the trajectory
inference problem.
And this means that numerically
it is very simple to come up
with a MAP estimate.
There's an interesting
fact that comes out
of the algebra involved,
namely, that the MAP
estimate of each one
of the parameters
turns out to also be a linear
function of the observations.
We saw this property
in the estimators
that we derived for simpler
cases in this lecture sequence.
It turns out that this
property is still true.
And this is an appealing
and desirable property
because it means that these
estimators can be applied very
efficiently in
practice without having
to do any complicated
calculations.
Finally, there's a number of
important facts, some of which
we have seen in
our examples which
are true in very big generality.
One fact is that the maximum a
posteriori probability estimate
of some parameter
turns out to be
the same as the conditional
expectation of that parameter.
Furthermore, if you look at
this joint density of all
the Theta parameters
and from it you
find the marginal density
of the Theta parameters
always within this
conditional universe.
It turns out that this marginal
posterior PDF is itself normal.
Since it is normal, its mean--
which is this quantity--
is going to be
equal to its peak.
And therefore, it is equal
also to the MAP estimate that
would be derived from
this marginal PDF.
So what do we have here?
There are two ways of coming
up with MAP estimates.
One way is to find the
peak of the joint PDF,
and then read out the
different components of Theta.
Another way of coming
up with MAP estimates
is to find for each
parameter the marginal PDF
and look at the peak
of this marginal PDF.
It turns out that for this
model these two approaches
are going to give
you the same answer.
Whether you work with the
marginal or with the joint,
you get the same MAP estimates.
And this is a reassuring
property to have.
Finally, as in the examples that
we have worked in more detail,
it turns out that the mean
squared error conditioned
on a particular observation
is the same no matter
what the value of
that observation was.
And furthermore, there are
fairly simple and easily
computable formulas that
one can apply in order
to find what this
mean squared error is.
So to summarize,
this class of models
that involve linear relations
and normal random variables
have a rich set of important
and elegant properties.
This is one of the reasons
why these models are
used very much in practice.
And they're probably the
most widely used class
of statistical models.